uh all right turning now to our series
the dish this morning we're introducing
you to a chef making a name for himself
with a unique approach to Pizza we all
know about a classic New York slice
right we all know that a hearty Chicago
deep dish and even a crispy Detroit pan
pizza but we are betting that you have
never heard of Pittsburgh style pizza
and not only have you probably not heard
of it you definitely wouldn't expect to
find it in Los Angeles which notoriously
lacks its own Signature variety of pizza
so Jamie yukis has been exploring in LA
and shows us a spot called gorilla pies
bringing some unlikely Pittsburgh flare
to the City of Angels for a taste of the
Steel City look no further than LA's San
Fernando Valley here at an unassuming
strip mall next to a kosher bakery in a
Jewish neighborhood you'll find gorilla
pies where Chef Ben osher is combining a
wild mix of flavors you'd never expect
to find on a pizza it's a hybrid kimchi
and sauerkraut
oh that's good it's like a little salty
a little crunchy a little spicy that's
what osher calls crouchy and it goes on
a pizza named the rabbi it's basically a
Reuben sandwich on a pie with his take
on Thousand Island as the base followed
by swiss cheese purple cabbage Pastrami
and even caraway seeds to make the crust
smell and taste like seeded rye bread
Jake osher is Ben's brother the Shop's
co-owner and its unofficial Pizza taste
tester the crazier it is like who knows
the better for me and that's part of the
Pittsburgh style right absolutely
anything goes if you've not heard of
Pittsburgh style pizza Ben thinks he may
be the first to coin the term part of
the secret that's our Standard Pizza
cheeses half mozzarella half provolone
that's a very Pittsburgh influence and
if it all seems a bit orthodox well read
the sign on the door it's osher not
Kosher Ben's inspiration comes from an
extensive culinary past including a
stint and a michelin-starred Indian
restaurant and years at the high-end
Sushi giant Nobu do you use what you
learn from Nobu even in your pizza now
absolutely Japanese food is all about
finding the best quality ingredients and
not messing with them too much and
presenting them in a very beautiful way
Ben's career came to a head in 2020 he
was working as the executive chef at a
hotel in Hollywood and lost his job
during the pandemic so he began
experimenting with new ideas in his
apartment to the Delight of his brother
who is living just a short stroll away
we got cauliflower pork belly classic
margarita it was pretty complicated and
the pizzas didn't even fit in my oven
well it sounds like a gorilla Pizza
exactly that's gorilla like the Warfare
but the pizzas didn't stay underground
for long we were playing around with
names like that I'm like why don't we
just do gorilla the animals so we had
the name The Branding the food's amazing
and we're like let's just try selling
home-cooked pizza via social media
gorilla pies quickly gained a reputation
in the neighborhood and then someone
called the health department so I kind
of took that as an omen that it was like
time to stop doing the pop-up and go
legit my father just started doing
research and found this listed on
Facebook via a website called selling
restaurants.com who knew that existed
this space had previously been a kosher
Pizzeria and though that's no longer the
case Ben told us maintaining the spot's
Jewish identity is a point of Pride tell
me about that picture in front of you so
yeah so uh to our best knowledge It Is
1920 Toledo Ohio and we think due to the
apples on the table that it's Rosh
Hashanah
um and the baby that's my great aunt wow
wow and I love this guy he's my favorite
do you know who he is a relative and
Uncle we'll just call him the rabbi this
Rabbi isn't kosher no no he's still a
Jew after meeting the namesake of
gorillapai's signature Pizza we went
into the kitchen to make it
and just a few minutes later this is
smelling amazing it was time to sit down
for some slices with the OSHA Brothers
we tried the kitten Ben's take on a
margarita pizza the green monster a
pesto pie topped with fried shiitake
mushrooms and of course the rabbi do you
already have two down
don't judge me
this is my job
for Ben osher the gig is sentimental a
former fine dining Chef getting back to
the preferred comfort food of his
childhood I'm inspired by pizza pizza is
universal you know you hard-pressed to
find anybody on the planet that's like
pizza no I don't want that now first
Los Angeles
and now you know what Pittsburgh style
pizza is so you learned something today